Wilfrid Schwartz ira-t-il en cassation à
cette heure le maire de la riche et nous
indique qu'il n'a pas pris sa décision
en jeu ni plus ni moins que sa carrière
politique le jugement de la Cour d'appel
d'Orléans l'oblige en effet à quitter
tous ces mandats seuls pour voir
suspendrait cette décision dans sa ville
en tout cas chacun s'est forgé son avis
romain Delville
contacté par nos soins où est Wilfrid
Schwartz indiqué qu'il n'allait pas
répondre aux questions sur cette affaire
et qu'il n'avait pas pris de décision en
fin de matinée quant à ce pour voir en
cassation cette affaire c'est l'affaire
de la gifle assénée à son directeur de
cabinet quand le maire de La Riche était
président de la métropole et qui lui
vaut depuis hier d'être condamné en
appel à six mois d'inel éligibilité pour
cet habitant de La Riche l'idée que
Wilfrid Schwartz ne siège plus au
conseil municipal est une mauvaise
nouvelle c'est désolant quoi j'ai
honnête c'est désolant parce que ça
restait un bon maire
après ce qui est eu je vais dire des
problèmes et puis que c'est mal tourné
je suppose que la personne en face a dû
vraiment le pousser dans de ses limites
parce que c'est quelqu'un de patient
6 mois d'innéligibilité signifie qu'il
devrait quitter le conseil municipal de
La Riche par conséquent le Conseil
métropolitain est laissé sa place au
conseil départemental à son remplaçant
Bernard Desrosiers une décision juste
pour cette larichoise
ça va lui permettre de réfléchir un
petit peu à plus tard
de se contenir déjà parce que bon je
trouve que franchement c'était pas son
rôle de faire ça il aurait pu au moins
se contenir quant à l'ancien maire de La
Riche Alain Michel 5 mandats jusqu'en
2014 et qui regrette d'avoir soutenu où
est freech Schwartz pour prendre sa
succession il considère que son ancien
directeur de cabinet devrait se retirer
de la vie politique quand il y a un
management toxique
ça se répercute évidemment dans les
services et ça se répercute également
dans dans la mise en oeuvre des projets
que donc la ville empathie forcément la
métropole en apathie aussi les habitants
n'empathie et les agents municipaux
également ont souffert ce pour voir en
cassation ne ferait que retarder
l'échéance de son inéligibilité nul
doute que Wilfried Schwartz biberonner
aux jeux politiques depuis sa jeunesse
étudiante cherchera une stratégie pour
retrouver son mandat local